>> SCOTT MASON, YOU HELPED US
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>>> ALSO THIS MORNING, THOUSANDS
OF MIGRANTS ARE NOW FACING
POTENTIALLY MONTHS OF MORE
UNCERTAINTY AFTER THE SUPREME
COURT'S DECISION THAT THE BORDER
RESTRICTION, TITLE 42, IS GOING
TO REMAIN IN EFFECT FOR NOW.
IT WAS A BRIEF UNSIGNED ORDER
FROM THE JUSTICES YESTERDAY THAT
HALTED A TRIAL JUDGE'S RULING
THAT WOULD HAVE LIFTED THE
MEASURE.
THIS IS THE MEASURE THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE EXPULSION OF MIGRANTS
WHO COULD SEEK ASYLUM.
INSTEAD THE COURT GRANTED THE
REPUBLICAN-LED REQUEST TO
PREVENT THE WINDING DOWN OF
TITLE 42.
THE COURT SAID IT WILL HEAR
ARGUMENTS FROM THE CASE, FROM
THE REPUBLICAN-LED STATES IN
FEBRUARY.
ROSA FLORES IS LIVE IN EL PASO,
TEXAS.
YOU'VE BEEN REPORTING HOW THE
MIGRANTS ARE FEELING.
I'M SURE A LOT OF THEM ARE
CONFUSED BY WHAT THIS
DEVELOPMENT MEANS FOR THEM.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE RIGHT,
KAITLAN.
THERE IS A LOT OF CONFUSION
BECAUSE THESE MIGRANTS ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT'S
GOING TO IMPACT THEM.
THIS IS ON A CASE-BY-CASE BASIS
SO IT DEPENDS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN THE STATES IN
EL PASO, THERE'S A SENSE OF
CALM.
SO THEY'RE FOCUSSING ON THE
BASICS, FOOD AND SHELTER.
1-YEAR-OLD BRENDA HAS NO SHOES.
HER TINY FEET, BARE ON THE COLD
PAVEMENT OF A PARKING LOT.
HER PARENTS ANTHONY AND AND
GLENDA SAY THEY WRAPPED THIS
ROSERY AROUND HER ANKLE FOR
PROTECTION WHEN THEY LEFT
VENEZUELA FOUR MONTHS AGO AND
SAID IT SAVED HER LIFE MULTIPLE
TIMES IN THE JUNGLE BETWEEN
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA.
HE SAYS THAT THE MOST DANGEROUS
PART OF THE JOURNEY WAS THROUGH
THE DARIAN GAP, THEY SAY THEY
SAW ADULTS WHO DIED, CHILDREN
WHO DIED.
BRENDA'S MOST RECENT BRUSH WITH
DEATH, CROSSING THE RIO GRAND
INTO EL PASO.
SHE SAID SHE THOUGHT HER
DAUGHTER WAS GOING TO DIE
OVERNIGHT BECAUSE IT WAS SO
COLD.
THEY HAD JUST CROSSED THE RIVER,
THEY WERE WET.
DESPERATE, SHE SAID SHE STARTED
KNOCKING ON DOORS ASKING FOR
HELP.
SHE SAID THAT SHE PRAYED TO GOD,
THAT SHE HUGGED HER DAUGHTER AS
TIGHT AS SHE COULD AND TRIED TO
WARM HER WITH HER OWN BODY HEAT
AS MUCH AS SHE COULD TO TRY TO
SAVE HER DAUGHTER'S LIFE.
THE FAMILY IS PART OF THE
GROWING NUMBER OF MIGRANTS
CROSSING INTO THE U.S. DURING
THE LATEST SURGE.
THIS AS THE SUPREME COURT RULED
THAT THE TRUMP ERA PUBLIC HEALTH
RULE, TITLE 42, REMAINS IN PLACE
WHILE THE LEGAL CHALLENGES PLAY
OUT.
MIGRANTS LIKE THEM LINE THE
STREETS OF EL PASO NEAR A
CATHOLIC CHURCH THAT TURNS INTO
A SHELTER OVERNIGHT.
MANY HERE HAVE NO MONEY FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND SOME HAVE NO
FAMILY IN THE UNITED STATES.
HE SAID THEY DON'T KNOW ANYONE.
THE TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD ERECTED
OVER 2 MILES OF FENCING ALONG
THE U.S. SIDE OF THE RIO GRAND
IN EL PASO IN THE PAST WEEK.
THE BARRIER IS NOT DETERRING UP
TO 1,600 MIGRANTS BORDER PATROL
IS ENCOUNTERING EVERY DAY.
MIGRANTS LIKE SELENA, A
VENEZUELAN MOTHER OF TWO HAS
DECIDED TO WAIT IN MEXICO WHERE
SHE SAID SHELTERS ARE AT
CAPACITY.
WHICH MEANS, SLEEPING ON THE
STREET.
OFFICIALS THERE SAY THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY MIGRANTS ARE
WAITING IN THEIR CITY FOR TITLE
42 TO END.
ADVOCATES AND OFFICIALS IN THE
THREE NORTHERN MEXICAN CITIES
ESTIMATE NEARLY 22,000 MIGRANTS
ARE WAITING IN SHELTERS, ON THE
STREETS, AND IN CAMPS.
AS FOR THE BLANCOS, THEY CREDIT
THE ROSERY FOR SAVING THEM
DURING THEIR JOURNEY.
BRENDA AND HER PARENTS ARE STILL
HERE IN EL PASO, THEY'VE BEEN
STAYING AT THAT PARKING LOT THAT
YOU SAW IN THE STORY.
HER PARENTS ARE TRYING TO RAISE
MONEY, POPPY, TO GET OUT OF THE
BORDER AREA, OUT OF EL PASO.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY
AND THEY DON'T HAVE ANY FAMILY
IN THE UNITED STATES, AND THAT'S
THE SITUATION THAT A LOT OF
THESE MIGRANTS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO ARE IN.
THEY DON'T HAVE MONEY, THEY
DON'T HAVE CONNECTIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES AND SO THEY'RE
STUCK HERE.
>> I THINK WHAT OFTEN GETS LOST,
ROSA, THANK YOU FOR THAT GREAT
REPORTING, WHAT GETS LOST IN
THIS CONVERSATION IS THAT TO
SEEK ASYLUM IS A LEGAL ACTION.
IT IS LEGAL FOR PEOPLE TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND SEEK
ASYLUM IN THE UNITED STATES.
BUT YOU HAVE SOME REALLY
INTERESTING REPORTING ON HOW
BACKLOGGED THAT SYSTEM IS FOR
PEOPLE THAT EVEN GET IN THAT
LINE.
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AND THE BACKLOG IS OF HISTORIC
PROPORTIONS.
THERE'S A GROUP AT SYRACUSE
UNIVERSITY THAT CRUNCHES ALL
THIS DATA AND ACCORDING TO THEIR
DATA, THE NUMBER OF IMMIGRATION
CASES, IMMIGRATION COURTS HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES AND AT
USCIS NEARS 1.6 MILLION CASES.
THEY SAY THIS IS THE HIGHEST ON
RECORD.
AND THEY SAY IT'S A 7-FOLD
INCREASE SINCE 2012.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S THE IMPACT
OF TITLE 42 ON ALL OF THIS?
EFFECTIVELY TITLE 42 STOPS
MIGRANTS FROM GOING TO A PORT OF
ENTRY AND SEEKING ASYLUM, WHICH
IS SUPPOSED TO BE LEGAL IN THE
UNITED STATES, BUT THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF TITLE 42.
BUT THE IMPACT IS BAUDS OF THE
SURGE THAT'S HAPPENING, BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY MIGRANTS COMING
TO THE BORDER HOPING TO ENTER
THE UNITED STATES, THOSE NUMBERS
ARE SHOOTING THROUGH THE ROOF.
POPPY, BETWEEN OCTOBER AND
NOVEMBER, THAT FEDERAL DATA
SHOWS THAT MORE THAN 30,000
ASYLUM CASES WERE ADDED JUST
DURING THAT SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
AND THAT'S EXPECTED TO CONTINUE.
AS YOU CAN SEE BEHIND ME A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE, WHAT THEY WANT
IS ASYLUM.
AND HERE'S THE THING.
THE WAIT JUST FOR A HEARING
RIGHT NOW, ACCORDING TO THIS
GROUP, COULD BE MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS.
POPPY.
>> AND THEY CAN'T LEGALLY WORK
DURING THAT TIME, RIGHT?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IF THEY ARE NOT HERE LEGALLY IN
THE UNITED STATES, THEY CAN'T
WORK.
ONCE THEY ARE IN THE ASYLUM
PROCESS, LEGALLY THEY CAN FILE
FOR AN APPLICATION FOR A WORK
PERMIT, BUT I'VE COVERED THOSE
STORIES, TOO, THERE'S BEEN
BACKLOGS THERE, TOO, SO IF THEY
QUALIFY FOR THE WORK PERMIT,
SOMETIMES THERE ARE DELAYS ON
THAT, AND THEIR HANDS ARE TIED.
THEY CAN'T WOR